[Music]
my name is Sharon I'm just a ticked off
hairdresser with a fo headache I'm good
at plenty of things taking no for an
answer ain't one of
them you just wandered into a lady you
never met before his funeral why exactly
something about that little girl just
five and she already needs a liver
[Music]
transplant hi Sharon remember me yes
ma'am so she's going to help out if you
nights
I met this woman she's a mess perfect
she'll fit right
in I'm going to put together a press kit
for Michelle get corporate donations
that kind of thing we don't need to be
running around worried about money and
bills right now I just want to be with
my family I about saying yes and then
figuring out how girls help your daddy
out I'm not comfortable with this I'm
her father I'm supposed to be the they
want taking care of her you're going to
have to get comfortable being
uncomfortable cuz this ain't about you
it's about your little girl
when Michelle will need to fly to the
Children's Hospital immediately I've had
patients who have missed that window
because they couldn't get a flight now
lose your faith over
this officials are saying be prepared
for what they're calling the worst
blizzard in State
history is
it
today okay we'll be there
you want to go on an adventure I let you
go the roads haven't been plowed the the
airport's closed honey listen it's it's
too dangerous I have to make it this is
our last chance if we don't take you
Michelle
[Music]
dies someone's got to do something
someone's got to fight
for but one thing I know for sure that
little girl now has the entire city
rooting for
[Music]
her I want you to know something you're
not just worthy Sharon you're a
[Music]
miracle
a